>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Now we're going to welcome
to the stage Amy Sarig King.
[ Applause ]
>> Amy Sarig King: How's it going?
Awesome. Hello.
Can you hear me out there?
Fantastic.
You know, I prepare for
things really seriously.
I've been writing for 25 years.
I lecture in places,
and I'm really prepared.
And today, I thought,
I'm going to wing it.
The reason is, is because in
a way, even though I've talked
about this book in other
places, I've never really figured
out who the new persona is, right,
because I write young adult novels.
So I usually talk to university
students and high school students.
And then I wrote a
middle grade novel.
And I have a nine-year-old at
home, so I know how I talk to her.
And then it turns out, I talk
to her the exact same way
as I talk to everybody else.
And I don't have to
invent a persona at all.
I can just be me.
But I'm here to talk about
"Me and Marvin Gardens."
It's a novel that's
really close to my heart.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about it,
and then I'm going
to read a tiny but.
But really, because my name is
asking, I'm all about the questions.
Are you guys up for some
questions and answers?
Great. You can talk to me
about how it took me 15 years
to get published, or
how I write a book
or how I tap dance,
any of those things.
I'm open to all of those things.
But I just want to tell you
a little bit about the book.
It's interesting.
I sat down to write the
book with one thing in mind:
I wanted to write a book about
an animal that eats plastic
and that could solve the world's
plastic pollution problem.
And this is interesting
because I love science.
I've always loved science.
So when I write middle grade,
I get to write about science.
And I'm writing my next one now,
and there's more science in that.
Anyway. So I sat down to write
about this animal who eats plastic.
And what actually came out of me
was this 30-year-old story of stuff
that actually happened to me.
And this just tends to happen.
Like I said, I've written
more than 20 novels.
This happens every time.
So in this book, you'll
meet Obe Devlin.
He's a boy.
He grew up simple, in nature,
surrounded by 50 acres of cornfield,
a bubbling creek, and a
200-year-old oak tree.
And he was connected to the land
through his family's history.
It was his family's
land at one time.
And he only had one best friend, had
one friend because, just like me,
growing up in the middle
of a cornfield and growing
up in a rural area, you really only
have one friend if you're lucky.
And they used to explore the
wilderness together, right.
But then, meet the developers,
who buy the wilderness,
and they level it, and
they plant house seeds,
and then houses grow
instead of corn.
And meet the new kids in Obe's new
development, and his best friend has
to disown him in order to make
friends with these new kids.
And his life would really
never be the same after that.
He thought everything was
just bummer from there on out.
But then he meets putrid Annie,
who might have been named after me.
I may have been called
putrid Amy, once at least.
Anyway, she's a nature loving girl,
and she lives in the
new development too.
But she teaches Obe that
new kids can be kind.
And then, of course, Obe meets
Marvin Gardens, a strange creature
who he finds in the creek one night,
munching on a plastic water bottle.
So like I said, like Obe,
I grew up in the middle
of that same cornfield, near
that same 200-year-old oak tree.
And like Obe, I heard stories about
how that land was our family's land,
until my grandfather, who was an
alcoholic, drank 175 acres of it
and left our family with nothing.
And like Obe, I struggled
with new kids, suburban kids,
who had no interest
in crayfish or dirt.
Except in my case, my best friend
didn't defect to the other side.
She just moved to Connecticut.
But that was the same summer that
the bulldozers came and woke me
up every morning with
that beep, beep, beep,
beep beeping that they
do when they back up.
The only thing Obe and I don't have
in common is the plastic
eating animal.
Now I was a farmer in Ireland.
I lived in Ireland for 15 years.
I was a self-sufficient farmer.
And if you want to know
about what that means,
ask me what does that really mean.
But I'll tell you now.
It means I didn't buy anything
for ten years, not one thing.
Oh, give me a second.
Give me like five more
minutes, all right.
I promise, you'll be
the first one I call on.
So I was on this farm in
Ireland, and I had goats.
And the goats kind of were the
closest thing to Marvin Gardens.
But honestly, they'll eat anything.
But when I started
researching for this book,
it was kind of interesting
because, I mean,
like this animal only
eats plastic, okay.
Marvin, that's all he eats,
only plastic, like for real.
So some of the research I did
for this book really
bummed me out, you guys.
It really bummed me out.
And I'm sorry to do this
to you right after lunch,
but I'm just going to throw out
a few things that I learned.
So here's two.
It takes a plastic bottle
500 years to decompose.
Americans throw away 2.5 million
of these bottles per hour.
More than 1 million plastic
bags are used every minute.
About 80% of the trash in our
landfills could be recycled.
And then I want to talk to
as well, just for kicks.
I don't know.
Have you guys ever heard of the
Great Pacific Garbage Patch?
Yeah, you've heard of it?
Okay. Some of you might
know about it;
some of you might not know about it.
I always saw it, and a lot of
times when we look at the articles
about the Great Pacific Garage
Patch, we see like plastic bottles
and plastic bags floating.
And we've heard it's
the size of Texas.
And then we've heard
this: it's the size
of the continental United States.
In actual fact, it could be either.
Depending on the day, the
size changes quite often.
But the Great Pacific Garbage
Patch is actually not plastic
things floating.
It's not just the way
we imagine garbage.
Some of you may know this,
but the Great Pacific Garbage Patch
is an area in the Pacific gyre,
which is the middle of the Pacific,
okay, where the water has become
so polluted with microplastics, that
means like tiny plastics, all right,
that it almost looks like gel.
Now think of the size of Texas, size
of the continental United States.
And it almost looks like gel, or
actually, Obe in the book refers
to it as confetti gel because there
are so many trillions of pieces
of tiny, little microplastics
in this water.
Actually, just to bum you out a
little more after lunch, sorry,
there are two major garbage patches
in the Pacific and
one in the Atlantic.
We just don't talk about
that one very much.
So before writing this
book, I recycled casually.
Now, I recycle like a maniac.
I was going upstairs, putting
my Fritos in the one place
and the bag in the other.
That's me.
But I also started
calling my best friend,
who moved to Connecticut,
more often.
And it also made me rescue a kitten,
okay, because when I left the farm
in Ireland, that would be 13
years ago, I left it all behind.
I loved that farm.
I built it with my two hands.
Well actually, my husband and
I built it with our four hands.
I should give him some credit.
But I had had animals.
I went from walking around
with chickens on my shoulders
and having goats and chasing horses
that got lose and I came back
to America and I decided
no pets, no animals.
That's it.
I became this like
cold pet-less person.
And then I adopted this kitten,
and her name is Ziggy Jack.
And she's brought me back
to the person that I was
when I was actually Obe's age,
because though I was severely
allergic to cats at that age,
all I wanted was a kitten.
And now, I'm not severely allergic
anymore, and now I've got a kitten.
So basically, if you know me
and you're here, if you know me
for my other work, if you know me
from any place you've ever
seen me speak, if you read "Me
and Marvin Gardens," you're going
to see a little bit of me in it
because really, it's
my family's life.
I was thrilled to be able to explore
what was going on 100 years ago
when my grandfather
was losing our land.
But it would be Obe's
great-grandfather.
I'm going to read a
tiny piece of the book.
And checking my time.
And then I'm just going to
go for questions and answers
because you guys look
really curious.
And I mean that in the nice way.
I'm going to read you just a
little piece of how Obe and Annie,
his friend Annie on the bus, and
how they interact with each other.
And so, let's see.
You need to know, all right,
Obe lives on the farm.
They're starting build these houses.
Annie lives in the
development as well.
So she's on the same
bus route as him.
And if I've forgotten anything else,
I'll just throw it
in while I'm reading.
That's just how I roll today.
So okay. And Mike,
Mike was his -- Sorry.
Tommy is his old best friend, and
Tommy's new best friend is Mike.
He's kind of mean because
mean people exist.
I still don't understand that.
I just want to let you know.
I don't know how mean
people exist, but they do.
All right.
We had seating assignments
on the bus.
Six months ago, Tommy switched
to sit with his new friend Mike.
And the bus driver told him that
it was the only switch he'd get.
In the switch, I got to
sit next to Annie Bell,
who the boys called putrid Annie
because she threw up in school once.
Annie was in the fifth grade and
moved here from Portland, Oregon,
right before winter break.
She lived in phase one
of the development.
I liked her because she was the one
kid on the bus who wasn't trying
to prove something to anyone.
She said the boys who called her
putrid Annie were just dumb and weak
because they couldn't
think for themselves.
And that was probably true.
The only thing I really knew about
Mike, Tommy's new best friend,
was that he'd accidently shot
his younger brother in the foot
with a BB gun when he was little.
His little brother still
had the BB in his foot.
I'd seen it.
Other than that, Mike didn't seem
to have much of a personality.
He didn't have hobbies.
He didn't get good grades.
He didn't care about much.
Annie cared about pretty
much everything.
She loved two things
especially: rocks and water.
Sorry, I mean weather.
I don't know what's
wrong with these glasses.
It's not me.
It's the glasses.
Rocks and weather.
She wanted to be a
geologist or a meteorologist.
Whenever she found a rock, she'd
talk about how old it might be.
She told me all about
the geologic timescale,
which was like pretending the
earth was a cake, with layers,
and some layers were
older than other layers.
She also believed the weather
in Portland, Oregon was superior
to the weather in Reading,
Pennsylvania.
So we'd argue about that sometimes
but never really argue, argue.
Annie played the cello.
I also played the cello.
So I get to be Obe and
Annie in this book.
It's kind of weird.
Anyway. Annie played the cello.
So on orchestra days, she'd
have to fit both herself
and her cello into our seat.
Because of how big the cello was,
she had to squeeze in close to me
and put the cello in the aisle seat.
I didn't mind.
There was nothing putrid
about Annie.
What's wrong with you, she asked
when she got on that morning.
What? You look happy or something.
I can't be happy?
Not on a Tuesday, no.
She said, you're supposed to
be mopey and kind of annoyed.
I laughed.
Oh my gosh, you're laughing now.
That's worrying.
Stop it or I'll laugh more, I said.
I'll be you then.
Look, mopey, annoyed.
She held her face in
this frozen look of pain.
Is that what it was
like to be my friend,
to have to look at
that all the time?
The bus was worse than
anywhere else, I knew that.
Tommy and his new friends
were there.
Maybe I was happier off the bus.
I couldn't tell.
It's hard to see yourself when
you are yourself, I guess.
Annie still had that look on her
face, like she was trying hard
to look mean or something.
You can stop now, I said.
Good. She smiled.
It's tiring being you.
I reached into my pocket and
found the tiny rock I'd picked
up at the creek.
I gave it to her.
Quartzite.
She said, good job rock hound.
I smiled. I'm going to leave it at
that because you guys look curious.
But I'm not telling you
the spoilers in this book.
There is a mystery animal, and there
is a secret that Marvin Gardens has.
He's not all great.
And eating plastic bottles
does have its side effects.
That's all I'm going to say.
But if anything, if I
can make, I don't know,
if I can make us all think a
little bit more about pollution
and what we do with our trash and
what we do when we walk by trash
on the street, then I feel
like I've done my job.
So I'm going to go to
questions and answers now.
And I already promised
somebody he'd be the first one.
Hold up. Where were you?
Is that you?
Yes. You're going to
have really yell.
>> I like science too.
>> Amy Sarig King:
You like science too?
All right.
I love science.
Yes. Oh, I didn't hear you.
What? You love nature.
What's your favorite part of nature?
Trees, birds, what?
Having fun with it.
Awesome. Excellent.
Nature is awesome.
There's no doubt about it.
I'm coming over there in a second.
Yes.
>> Are you going to write a sequel?
>> Amy Sarig King: Am I
going to write a sequel?
I'm not. I am not a sequel writer.
I have about eight or nine published
novels and none of them are --
They're connected funnily enough.
A lot of time, they're
set in the same place.
So the next one is set
in a similar place,
but they're not connected, no.
Yes. Am I going to
publish another book?
I'm going to publish books
till I die, if they let me.
That's pretty much my whole point.
I hear you back there, Mary.
Can't miss that laugh.
You're awesome.
Yeah, until I'm toast, I'm going
to publish books because I'm here
to ask questions and
help you ask questions.
What else do you have?
You've got to have something for me.
Yeah. What is the plastic
eating creature called?
He's name Marvin Gardens.
And you won't believe it, but he has
a wife, and her name is Boardwalk.
Do any of you ever play -- I know.
Have you ever played Monopoly?
There's a lot of monopoly fun in
this book and not so much fun, too,
because their dad plays with them,
and he always wins,
just like my dad.
Actually, I'm 47 years old.
And last month, I beat my father
in ping-pong for the first time,
and I gloated and I
strutted around the place
because he never let
me win as a child.
And then he wanted a
rematch and I said no.
It was awesome.
Somebody had their hand
up over that direction,
but I don't know who it was.
All right.
Yes. What's my favorite
thing to what?
Oh, what was my favorite
thing to do on the farm.
Wow, that's a great question.
I really loved breeding chickens.
Here's a weird sorry for you.
This will be weird.
You ready?
So since I was self-sufficient,
I didn't make any money, okay.
I grew my own food.
I grew my own whatever I
was eating, whether it was,
sorry for the vegetarians in the
room, whether it was a chicken
or whether I could trade some things
for half of another sort of animal
or whether it was vegetables.
I grew everything myself.
So I didn't have any money.
So all this time, I
was writing, right.
So I finally got a computer.
I built one actually.
And, I mean, I built
one out of components.
I didn't make the components
because that would be crazy.
But I built this computer, and I
was writing novels on the computer
because I started on
a typewriter, right.
And the only way I could send my
books out and the letters out to go
like to publishers was I had
to hatch chickens or ducks.
And I bred rare poultry.
So I got some decent money.
Like per chicken, I'd maybe
get 20, 20 euros per chicken.
But I'd have to wait 21 weeks.
So if I thought about it, okay, I
finish this novel, I'd have to think
about how many different agents
or publishers I wanted to query
and then hatch so many
chickens to cover the postage
and the photocopying and all
that stuff in order to send.
So the long answer was that one.
The short answer is chickens.
My favorite thing was chickens.
I loved my chickens.
I had some epic chickens.
Yes, sir.
I need you to speak up.
Oh, wonderful.
Got you. All right.
What does Marvin Gardens look like?
Well, you see, I can't tell
you because it's a secret.
But I can tell you
he's kind of slimy.
And when you pet him, it
kind of feels like snot.
That's all I can tell you.
Because he's an animal that's
never been discovered before.
So he's kind of like a hog and kind
of like a dog and kind
of like a mix.
The whole point of that part of
the book is your imagination.
Yeah. But he is slimy, like algae.
Yeah. What?
I used to name my chickens till
I started to eat my chickens.
And then I realized it was really
a bad idea to name your chickens.
So I do remember one
named Edna very fondly.
She was a lovely chicken.
But after that, no, no.
I didn't name my goats either.
I'm scanning.
What else you got?
Yes. Is your hand up?
Yeah? Excellent question.
How long did it take me to write?
This book took me probably
about probably a year to write.
Sometimes it depends
on the book, you know.
Sometimes it takes me ten
years to write a book;
sometimes it takes me a few months,
but everything has
to do with rewriting.
So I can write the book down,
but I have to keep writing it
and writing it to make it
better and better and better,
you know, make things match.
So about a year.
Yeah. Have I ever had
to do page one rewrite?
Every day of my life, all the time.
Yeah. Rewriting's my favorite thing.
Revision is everything.
I always say revision is
the sport, because it is.
It's like the thing you train for.
You get that first draft down
and then you realize some
of the stuff doesn't make sense,
and then you have to
connect it, you know.
But is page one rewrite
like a specific thing?
Oh yeah, I start over all the time.
You bet. Absolutely.
Although in fairness, this page
started similarly to how I did it
in the first draft,
but it got better.
Yeah. Which book do I like
the best that I've written?
That's -- It's the
weirdest book I ever wrote.
And it's actually for
an older audience.
It's for older teenagers
and for adults.
It's called "I Crawl Through It."
And it's a very strange book.
I think it's one of
the only surrealism,
what they call pure
surrealism, for teenagers.
I tend to be a bit
surreal anyway, so.
Yes.
>> What's the best
writing advice you ever got
from an elementary school teacher?
>> Amy Sarig King:
From an elementary school
teacher, best writing advice.
I had two of them that
used to hit me on the hand
because I didn't hold
my pencil right.
So I'm not going to
give them any credit.
Can I -- Well, I think
librarians are teachers too.
So actually, the best
writing advice I ever got was
from my elementary school librarian,
where any question I asked her,
it was Max and the Wild Things,
and I said, does he really go.
Does he really go to the
land of the wild things?
And she said, I don't know,
Amy, what do you think.
And I feel that my entire
career is owed to her.
Her name is Dawn Moan
[assumed spelling].
We're now Facebook friends,
and so I get to write
to her every now and
again and thank her.
But honestly, making
me think for myself,
making me answer questions instead
of telling me what
the book was about,
asking me what I thought it was
about was probably the smartest
thing any educator ever did for me.
Oh, hey, educators in the room.
Rock on. That's a true story.
All right.
Yes. Did I write the Wild Things?
I wish. No.
No. Maurice Sendak
wrote the Wild Things.
It's such a good book, isn't it?
Is he my friend?
No, sadly.
I'd like him to be my
friend, but that'll have
to happen at a later date.
[inaudible]
Yeah.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
To be a writer?
Honestly, when it comes
to young kids,
because I have this nine-year-old
who was once a seven-year-old,
and she wouldn't tell you
because her mom's a writer.
So she doesn't want to be a writer.
But she has it, she has it.
And the two things that I
would recommend is reading,
a lot of reading, and
a lot of writing,
and using your imagination
completely.
Like, my daughter once
said to me, she said, well,
I don't think I'm allowed to
draw the pictures in my book.
And I said, well, why
would you think that.
Of course, you can draw
the pictures in your book.
And so, she came back to
me with this picture book
about unicorns and, you know.
But the other thing is that, and
it's hard sometimes depending
on the age group and what age you
are, but I think a writer needs
to be able to spend time by
themselves and not be bored
and not always have -- And
that's the one thing I found
with my daughter.
So if you're bored and
it's summer vacation still,
which I don't think it
is down here anymore,
but if you're bored
next summer vacation,
instead of going I'm bored,
sit down with some paper
and see what you can come up with.
And don't try and plan
everything out.
Is that the second grader there?
Is that her?
Oh, okay, maybe.
All right.
Don't try and plan everything out.
Just sit down and go have fun.
Have fun. It takes a while, so why
not have fun while you're doing it?
So that's the best I can do.
I only got about three minutes,
so only a few more burning
questions, if you have any.
Yes, sir. I'm so sorry.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Do I think the plastic
problem could be solved?
It's pretty big.
And we have so many different types
of cultures in our world, right.
We have so many different places.
I can't do anything about
what other countries do.
I think the earth will probably
solve it one way or the other.
But I think that it'll
actually really harm us.
I mean, it's the same as what we're
seeing with climate change now.
It is real.
And I'll fistfight you for
that, not you personally,
but anybody who wants
to say it's not.
But the idea that it's
costing us so much money
and costing lives and
all these things.
Plastic pollution is doing the same
thing, usually actually in countries
that we don't talk about much.
So Southeast Asia.
It's really causing a huge amount of
problems in the actual population.
So I don't know.
I don't know can it be solved.
I'd like to think it can be.
I think we have to
start at the source.
What are we going to do
with this bottle today?
We're going to recycle it, right?
And if we can't recycle it, we'll
bring it home and recycle it
or we'll say to the teacher at
school, do you have a recycling bin.
Yes? Sound good?
That's what I do when
I go to schools.
They look at me like I'm
crazy, but I'm used to that.
So yeah.
>> So how do you feel about
the number of water bottles
that are being used in school
lunches and at school parties?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Amy Sarig King: Yep.
I know. It's weird.
I mean, it's funny.
There's a part in the book where
Obe turns around to his father
and he says, plastics
ruined everything.
And he goes, oh really,
plastics ruined everything.
And then he opens up the fridge,
and he says, look at this.
You milk, your yogurt,
your cheese, your meat.
And he just starts
listing everything.
Ketchup, your chocolate
syrup, this syrup,
all these -- Everything's
in plastic.
So it's not doing you -- And
look at the whole fridge.
It's plastic.
You know, it's not hurting you.
And so, I think that's one of
those things that we have that sort
of blinker vision on, you know.
But yeah, it's annoying.
I mean, I'd like to see, as
someone who goes to a lot
of schools throughout
the year, I would really
like to see more recycling bins in
schools because I know kids want to.
It's not just me.
Kids learn those things and they're
like, hey, what's up with this.
There's no recycling.
So yeah. I mean, most
of our convenient lunch
foods now are premade.
Our processed stuff is in plastic.
All right.
We have to wrap it up.
One more question.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I did purposely go with my full
name because my father used to say,
why aren't you using
my name anymore.
And that's a joke.
It was really just because,
yeah, I purposely did that.
And it was invigorating.
It was totally different, and I love
working with a different age group.
I still connect most with teenagers.
But that's not even true.
I like connecting with
nine-year olds.
eight-year olds.
So yeah. So far, so good.
It's been really quite cool.
That's why I'm writing another
one, because it's been interesting.
But I'm writing young adult, then
adult at the same time too, so.
Thank you so much for all your great
questions and for listening today.
Don't forget to recycle
your bottles, all right?
Promise?
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.